ونحييكم من جديد تبادل الاسرى بين الحكومه
اليمنيه والحوثيين تم تاجيله يوما واحدا
اي الى بعد غد الجمعه عوضا من غدنا الخميس
الذي كان قد تم الاتفاق عليه بين الطرفين
التاجيل الذي اعلن عنه او اعلن عنه
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الوفد الحكومي في
مفاوضات الاسرى والمختطفين ماجد فضائل عبر
تغريده على تويتر لم ياتي على ذكر اسبابه
لكنه اكد على ان عمليه التبادل تنطلق صباح
الجمعه المقبل وسوف تستمر ثلاثه ايام اي
ستنتهي الاحد بالاعداد والارقام المتفق
عليها وسيكون اول يوم من عمليه التبادل
عبر رحلات طيران متبادله للصليب الاحمر
بين عدن وصنعاء ستتبعها فيما بعد او في
اليوم التالي رحلات بين صنعاء والرياض
وابهى جنوب السعوديه والمخا غرب اليمن اما
اليوم الثالث ستكون هناك رحلات بين مارب
وصنعاء وفقا للمسؤول اليمني وبموجب
يفرج الحوثيون عن مئه وواحد وثمانين اسيرا
من جنسيات عده في مقابل 706 معتقلين لهم
لدى القوات الحكوميه عمليه التبادل هذه
ستتبعها عمليه تبادل اخرى في القريب حتى
يتم الافراج عن جميع المحتجزين والمختطفين
على قاعده الكل مقابل الكل وتصفير كل
المعتقلات والسجونه بحسب تعبيره اعود من
جديد الى ضيوف سيد بدر موضوع تبادل الاسرى
والذي اتى في اكثر من محادثات بين
الحوثيين اليمنيه الى اي مدى الاتفاق على
الاقل على هذا الموضوع بتصفير السجون يمكن
ان يكون بادره حسنيه بين الطرفين لمحاوله
التقرب والبناء فيما بعد على مسار سياسي
[موسيقى]
على الاقل جاهزيتها قبل ايام حتى
للبدء بهذه العمليه نعم دكتور علي الى اي
مدار موضوع الانساني موضوع على درجه بالغه
من الاهميه بالنسبه للطرفين نحن صحيح
نتحدث عن مسار سياسي تشوبه بعض التفاصيل
العسكريه كذلك ربما في حلقات قادمه سنتحدث
اكثر عن تفاصيلها لانها مهمه ولكن الجانب
الانساني ما مدى اهميته بعد سبع ثمان
سنوات من الاقتتال الداخلي
لا شك بان التقدم في الملف الانساني هو
يمهد السبيل
للتقدم في الملف السياسي طبعا هناك ترابط
بالتاكيد بين الملفين واعتقد انا بان
الافراج عن الاسرى والمقتطفين والمعتقلين
هذا سيشيع اقوى جديده اجواء قائمه على
الاستعداد للذهاب لما هو اكثر من ذلك
ولهذا الجميع ينظر الى هذا التبادل للاسرى
والمختطفين بانها عمليه مهمه ومن جانب
الحكومه انا اعتقد بان الحكومه يعني
ما موجود لديها هم اسرار مقاتلين تم القاء
القبض عليهم في الجبهات وهم يقاتلون بينما
اليوم اسرار اسرى الشرعيه وهم عباره عن
معتقلين ومختطفين وتم
جمعهم من من منازلهم لم يكونوا يحملوا
سلاح ولم يكونوا في الجبهات هذا انا اعتقد
ولكن الحكومه اليمنيه تتصرف بمسؤوليه وانا
اعتقد بان الافراج عن سياسيين وعن شخصيات
قياديه هو يخلق حاله من الارتياح
ويساعد فعلا في
السير قدما نحو معالجه الملف حتى النهايه
والانتقال للملفات الاخرى وبالذات الملف
السياسي التي يحتاج الى كثير من المهيدات
ومن ضمن هذه الامهات معالجه الجوانب
الانسانيه نعم سيد محمد منذ قليل في حديث
حضرتك عن امكانيه ان تكون هناك او يكون
وقف دائم لاطلاق النار حضرتك شككت في
نوايا
حركه انصار الله الحوثيه وقلت بانه فيما
سبق على الاقل استغلت هذه الهدنات لمحاوله
اعاده ترتيب الامور الان فيما يتعلق
بتبادل الاسرع هناك نوايا حقيقيه لتصفير
السجون هل عمليه تصفير السجون بمعنى صفر
مقابل صفر لا اسير من هذه الجهه ولا اسير
من الجهه المقابله وهذا يختلف عن مرات
السابقه هل هذا يوطد العلاقه على الاقل في
هذه المرحله
انا اعتقد ان اطلاق سراح المعتقلين
والمختطفين لدى الميليشيات الحوثيه وكذلك
اطلاق صراحه الاسرى والمعتقد
والمعتقلين لدى القوات الحكوميه هي اولى
خطوات السلام في اليمن بل انها تشكل
ارتياح كبير من الجميع لدى الجميع اليوم
انظار جميع اليمنيين في كافه المحافظات
اليمنيه متجهه نحو يعني تنتظر بلهفه اطلاق
سراح المعتقلين الذي
سيكون اولى خطوات اطلاق سراحهم يوم الجمعه
المقبله والتي
ترعاها الامم المتحده وكذلك الصليب الاحمر
نحن لدينا عمل كبير فيما يخص المعتقلين
لانه ملف انساني وكل يوم يبقى فيه
المعتقلين في السجون كل يوم تزداد معاناه
اسرهم معانات اهاليهم معاناه اقاربهم
وايضا معاناه المختطفين والمعتقلين انفسهم
الضيوف الكرام
اشاروا لنقاط مهمه ان الموجود لدى الشرعيه
الدستوريه هما معتقلين مدنيين تم اختطافهم
من الطرقات العامه من المساجد من الاحياء
السكنيه من منازلهم من مقر اعمالهم من
ايضا عبر يعني وسائل المواصلات سواء
الباصات او السيارات وغيرها من نقاط
التفتيش بالاضافه الى بعض المداهمات التي
شنت الميليشيات الحوثيه في بعض المحافظات
وزجت بالكثير من المدنيين في سجونها نحن
اليوم من خلال عمليات الرصد الميداني الذي
قمنا بها منذ بدايه الحرب حتى اللحظه
ميليشيات الحوثي اعتقلت اكثر من سته عشر
الف وثمانمائه مدني ما يتبقى في سجونها هم
اكثر من ثمانيه الف ومئتين مدني في مختلف
المحافظات التي تسيطر عليها اغلب
المعتقلين متواجدين في محافظه صنعاء في في
سجن الامن المركزي وكذلك في محافظه اب
وذمار وبعض السجون السريه التي تم انشاءها
من بعد انقلاب الميليشيات الحوثيه على
شرعيه الدستوريه
بينما مليشيات الحوثي في اول مفاوضات لها
في استوكهولم قدمت كشوفات للشرعيه ان
لديها سبعه الف ومئتين اسير لدى القوات
الشرعيه سواء كان في المحافظات الجنوبيه
او في محافظه مارب او كذلك في الساحل
الغربي من خلال التدقيق في الكشوفات
الميليشيات الحوثيه الذي تم تقديمها اغلب
الاسماء اسمها مكرره واسماء وهميه وبعضها
اسماء لاشخاص قد قتلوا في بعض الجبهات
الجدير بالذكر ان اغلب الاسماء المتواجده
في هذه قاعده البيانات التي تم تسليمها
والكشوفات هما قناصين ومقاتلين في الجبهات
ومشرفين على تجنيد صحيح في بعض المحافظات
صحيح ولكن استاذ محمد في كل الحالات يبدو
بانه تم ترتيب على الاقل يعني بعيدا عن كل
هذه التفاصيل وهي تفاصيل مهمه ولكن تم
ترتيب
تبادل عمليه الاسرى وحضرتك تقوم بانها
نقطه مهمه وخطوه يمكن بناء عليها استاذ
سالم الى جانب موضوع تبادل اسرع الجانب
الانساني اتفق كل ضيوف على انه اساسي
لمحاوله التقدم خطوه نحو الامام
لبناء اساس جيد لعلاقه ثنائيه بين الطرفين
الاساسيين في داخل اليمني ولكن ما النقاط
ما الملفات الاخرى في الملف الانساني الذي
قد نراه او قد نتابع تفاصيل قادما
اولا في الجانب الانساني الى جانب ما ذكره
الاخت انا في نظري ان هذا الاتفاق على
اطلاق سراح الكل مقابل الكل خطوه مهمه
للبناء لبناء الثقه وهذا لو نقفل فعلا او
لو نفذت هذه الخطوه الى الايام القريبه
المقبله سنكون قد بدانا تنفيذا الاتفاق
الذي تم بين الاطراف في الداخل اليمني هذا
اولا
لماذا حضرتك تشكك او تنتظر المزيد من
تفاصيل يعني منذ قليل الاستاذ بدر قال
بانه قد
نفهم بانه اجل اجلت عمليه تبادل الاسرى
لامور تقنيه امور طيران او امور تقنيه
اخرى حضرتك تقول لو تم ذلك هل نفهم بانه
هناك بعض التفاصيل التي ينتظر الاتفاق
عليها
لا حول الموضوع موضوع الاسرى لا يوجد هناك
بعض التفاصيل لكن نترك هامش قليل لربما
يحدث يعني امر ما في موضوع المفاوضات هناك
تتعجل احيانا بعض الخطوات لايام وبعضها
احيانا تلغى وبعضها يتم فيها من خلالها
تراجع لكن في هذه الخطوه انا لا اشكك انا
حقيقه متابع بشكل منتظم لموضوع موضوع هذا
الاتفاق الذي يتم بناءه الان وكنت على
يعني على معرفه بعض التفاصيل هذا الاتفاق
يمضي بشكل جيد انا اتفق انه اذا تعجل
سيكون بسبب يعني ترتيبات اجرائيه وترتيبات
ايضا لانجاح هذا التبادل لا اكثر من
الجانبين ليس تشكيكا ابدا المهم في النقطه
الثانيه ان الهدنه الخامسه سوف تكون لمده
سنه وهذا مهم جدا ايضا
لحقن الدماء ولا ايضا
يعني البدء في الهدوء والاستقرار على
مختلف النقاط النقاط المواجهه العسكريه
بين المديريات والمحافظات والمدن اليمنيه
وهذا جزء العام هذه السنه الاولى من ابريل
الحالي الى ابريل
قادمين هي سنه مهمه جدا فسيكون من خلالها
توقيع هذا الاتفاق ولكن اسالك اكثر عن هذه
الهدنه تتحدث عن الهدنه الخامسه التي
ستدوم سنه طيب هذه السنه ستكون مشابهه
للهودنات السابقه بمعنى انه يكون الموضوع
الانساني هو المبجل او هذه السنه لطولها
ستكون كذلك خاصه ببعض الترتيبات السياسيه
باختصار انت كرمت
ستكون للامرين لترتيبات السياسيه ولي ايضا
الجانب الانساني الهدنه ربما تستمر ست
شهور ربما يكون الحد الاقصى لها او محدد
لمده سنه بعد ذلك ننتقل الى المرحله
الانتقاليه لمده عامين يبدا من خلالها
الترتيبات للتشارك في الحكم والاتفاق على
مسيره موحده لليمن خلال الفتره المقبله
هذا الاتفاق الذي سوف يستمر لمده ثلاث
سنوات انا في نظري سنبداه بتبادل الاسرار
قريبا بعون الله تعالى على كل
سنتابع كل هذا ولكن في جزء اخر سنتحدث عن
الجانب الاقتصادي الجد مهم كذلك بعد فصل
قصير متابعينا نعود لنناقش
هل ينجح اليمنيون في التوصل الى توافقات
لاعاده توحيد اقتصادهم المنقسم سواء فيما
يتعلق بالبنك المركزي او بسعر صرف العمله
او الجمارك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات